all right y'all
let's go
okay welcome back
to you
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome everybody to
another episode
[Music]
wait a minute
you know what i just realized
we have to make this
public
so that's annoying
we make it public we save
there's always something
well i didn't do that right
but
here we are again and
i'm just gonna do the intro again
actually you know what i should need to
do is i need to stop this stream
and start it over that's what i'm gonna
do right now
here we
go ah whatever we'll just keep going
i'll just stop it when i do the audio
version of it i'm gonna
the audio i'm gonna cut this part of it
out i forgot to make it public
you know so i did it private but it is
what it is but welcome to the show
everybody and here we go
ladies and gentlemen
for the second time
we got it right this time welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
riffing with griffin
we out here trying to go difficulties
but we did it you watch it live i'm
streaming live on youtube right now
uh so thanks for being here make sure
you uh you know make sure you subscribe
and all that good stuff um
i'm gonna be talking about the super
bowl we'll be talking about my new couch
i'm gonna be talking about boba fett and
a couple of things that happened
over the weekend and what's been going
on in my life but for everybody here
welcome back
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody oh man i'm
so late getting the podcast in so much
stuff
uh
going on
uh before so i that's the only reason
why i didn't uh get the podcast done but
you know here we are
um wait let me make sure that this is
right
yeah so
you know
it was uh
it just was difficult to get everything
done this weekend because i i was i was
in missouri and shout out to everybody
that came to the shows in missouri it
was like actually really really great
group of people that came out
that um came to the show so i want to
say shout out to all those people that
came you know that came to the shows in
missouri really good people there so i
appreciate those people for coming out
and uh you know thank you everybody
who's here right now
watching me live making this happen
so um yeah i had that little uh oh but
you know you just remind me of something
before we start uh let's give it up for
door dash doordash get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first order of 15
or more when you download the door dash
app at enter and enter code griffin
whatever you want to enjoy tonight get
it from doordash
okay so here we are y'all and that's the
background for that but the real
background's gonna be this one here uh
unless i'm doing unless i'm depending on
whatever i'm talking about and that is
rachel one the battle and i have a new
couch
and there it is y'all the new couch is
in full effect
you know i was trying to sell the other
one i couldn't even sell it we could
have sold it but you know when you're
selling something to like regular people
it's like i don't want some regular
person coming to my place and then like
you know
and i also didn't want to do a thing i
didn't want to lift a finger to um
help take it out or do nothing like that
so
it just was like you know what i mean
you just want to like get so i had to
pay to get rid of it so you know maybe
they they sold it themselves and
somebody made some money off my couch
but whatever i had to get rid of it
happy life happy wife
but i actually love this new couch i got
it from hd buttercup you know it's
actually a dope ass couch
it's so comfortable uh you know now i
just watch tv and stuff and we lay there
cuddling and stuff it's like you know i
get what she wanted and we got it so
there's the new couch so you know you
want to see like the evolution of what
happened go look at rachel's instagram i
hate my boyfriend's couch
[Laughter]
so she made that instagram account it's
still live so we got to figure it out
whatever it is you know so um by the way
i just want to thank everybody for being
here make sure you share subscribe all
that stuff check me out on twitch on
twitch daily i'm gonna get on twitch
after this at eric griffin gaming check
me out there uh would love that
and um also
also
um
i will also be doing
you know
patreon
um you know patreon episodes so make
sure you join the patreon the the the
links in the bio there
you know i'm doing i'm doing i didn't do
one last week because i'm just having to
leave to go to missouri and all this
stuff but i'm gonna be doing more
patreon content
reviewing shows like if i start a review
on the regular river griffin i might do
all the other episodes but i'll do that
on the patreon only content you know so
so make sure you guys uh check that out
if you're interested if you want to
support or be a youtube member too so
the youtube members get it and the
patreon people get it and you could you
know just
come come right there if you want to
support and i appreciate the support
yeah so
the couch
we did it
got the new couch it was pretty simple
we got it we came there it is
so what did i do this weekend so i went
to missouri like to the blue room shout
out to those guys the hotel was really
nice it's a quaint little town
springfield missouri
you know the fun time you know the the
shows were great the people were great
you know i love that sort of like you
know midwest or i don't even know if
it's midwest but like middle of the
country sort of type of people who just
you know they pay the taxes they just
want to have they just want to live
their life you know you know they love
talking about stuff it's not so woke
you know it's like i actually like you
know like people like that so we we we
had a good time
rachel went to fashion week so rachel
went to new york to do fashion week and
then i went to missouri and then from
missouri
uh when i finished with that i went to
from missouri to vegas my buddy and i
jeff
one of my long time best friends jeff
shout out to jeff we go to we try to go
to vegas every year to watch the super
bowl because we love doing those dumb
prop bets and all that stuff in the
super bowl so you know let's just really
like get into it because this is what
we're here for that's what i'm here for
all about the super bowl and right up on
the screen there for you people watching
uh listening you don't get to see it but
you know that's the play that's there's
aaron donald going up against uh joe
burrow what an exciting super bowl
okay
just uh it was just it was so exciting
to watch
and i think because i had money on the
line you know uh it was it made it even
better i would have wanted to go to the
super bowl but it was like it was so
bougie like it seemed like it was so
bougie like
if i felt like even kanye west didn't
have good seats so it felt like it
leveled the playing field and this was
like a big star
big stars freaking super bowl party you
know
like if you listen to this week's cats
episode theo talks about all the people
he was hanging out with so that was
crazy and then you just see like you
know like adam devine and chloe was with
rebel wilson and and you know you know
all these people and you're just kind of
like damn it seemed like everywhere you
looked it was just
you know celebrities having like a big
ass super bowl party so you know right
you know it wasn't for regular people
ain't ashamed that i'm still coughing
it's so annoying but i do feel better my
voice is feeling better but i still have
a little post-nasal drip but it is what
it is anyways
so um like we get to vegas you know jeff
and i meet up in vegas i was staying at
mandalay bay
and
you know i go down to the sports book
and you know trying to do all these
crazy prop bets and up to that point i
had not decided who i wanted to bet on i
was like what do i want to bet on and so
i really thought about it and for me to
me it's like it's hard to bet against
joe burrow i just really thought that
you know
but i'm from la i wanted the rams to win
excuse me i wanted the rams to win the
game so it's like how do you bet so it's
so easy to bet like that because the
rams were favored by four four and a
half which that half is so stupid
because it's you know there's only a
it would be a weird way
well i guess
i guess somebody could be up ten six two
field goals that'd be four
so then they go four and a half meaning
you can't win by six you have to win by
you have to win by seven or you have to
lose by by four you know and then that
person that's how they get the person
when there's a win or loss there's no
tie so i saw that the rams were favored
by four and a half
so i thought oh i can get both both of
these
the bangles can cover
and i could win
um i can win i can win my bet and i
could get the rams to win so these are
the bets that i placed
i placed
i bet on the bengals to cover
so i just bet on them
and the under
because i looked at the history of the
playoffs with the bengals
and their defense has been balling
like their defense hasn't given up more
than 23 points
and i thought
i think for the bengals to win or keep
it close it would be a low-scoring game
so i was like let's do that you know i
said let's uh let's so i said so i went
bangles and the under that was my first
bet and then i picked some prop bets so
let me tell you the prop bets i picked
obj first touchdown
got it
uh rams to win between one and six
points
got it
um what was the other one um
oh [ __ ] i forgot what they were let me
see let me look at my let me look at my
phone because i want to get that right
uh
rams uh the one i didn't get was the
touchdowns one so rams my one to six
points i also picked exactly six
touchdowns i missed it by one i really
thought they scored six touchdowns but
they only scored five so i did not get
that one um i didn't get that one
but
wait there was there was one more i
forgot what it was but i think i tweeted
it so let me look at my tweets so i can
figure this damn thing out let me look
at my tweets from look yeah here we go
obj first time john ransom was next
sensing oh yeah that was it that was it
that was it that was it that was it six
total touchdowns ram spin one between
one and six obj first td so when obj got
that first td i was like we in this and
it was such an exciting game up to the
very end too because
i needed see i thought they had five
touchdowns
excuse me so i needed the rams
i needed the rams to go down the field
and score that touchdown because then
they would be up
you know but it would only be up by
three
so i needed them to get that touchdown
and then i needed the defense to stop
them
so because of like if joe burrow would
have kicked if they if joe barrow would
have put them down and they kicked the
field goal and tied the game i would
have lost my bet even if the rent
because it would have been over at that
point it would have been over because
the over was like 48 and a half that was
what the over was so they were already
at
23 what was it 23 20 i believe it was
yeah so that's 46. so for them to score
a touchdown a field goal it would it
would have messed me up so that's why i
was rooting for it and i had it it was
so dope when uh you know aaron donald
gets to sack and that was like great
so that's what i did so i won my bet i
didn't bet a lot i put 300 down on on
the one thing so that the 300 paid
i think the 300 paid whatever it was so
i ended up with like 1700 or something
like that with all the bets
so i mean it's not like i was going you
know
you know but when you do a parlay you
get more money off the bat so i ended up
with 1700 you know then i lost a
thousand at the crap table so you know i
don't know where i'm at
[Laughter]
but it was fun i had a really good time
but let's just talk about the super bowl
you know so the super bowl
the game itself i thought the game
itself was great i thought you know if
you think about it
there was a couple of turning points in
the game that i thought so when obj was
balling like balling like they were
trying to take cooper cup out of the
game and they pretty much were to a
certain extent of like double teaming
him and what it did was it left obj
who's also a number one receiver wide
open he was all over the field they were
just he was slinging him the ball he
scored a touchdown i was like oh man
rams about to do a route and then sadly
uh obj gets hurt and i don't i haven't
really heard any details
of what the injury was but it looked i
was like oh man did this guy tear his
mcl or some [ __ ] like that again
i was sad for him and he's such an
emotional dude so he was all crying but
at least we know he knows he had an
impact in that game he scored that
touchdown he was balling up to that
point so he deserved that super bowl
ring and i think it would have been a
route if it wasn't for that but who
knows because since he did their thing
so that was a great turning point in the
game
but then you talking about the rams
like stafford stafford was good but he
wasn't great
he wasn't great if he was great he would
have won the mvp he wasn't great you
look at all the sports shows they showed
a breakdown
when he was throwing to anyone else he
was terrible two interceptions like a 36
uh passer rating it was like it was
terrible but to cooper cup man it was
fantastic cooper cup that's why he got
the mvp i think aaron donald should have
been mvp but that's here nearly here no
there i think everybody did their part
everybody you know really contributed to
that victory and even if even if matthew
stafford would have got the mvp i
wouldn't have been upset about that
either i mean he did drive them down the
field 15 uh plays and got him in the end
zone
end zone two win the super bowl that
that's to do to mo he like has so many
fourth quarter comebacks you know his
numbers in detroit and how he played he
played freaking great and so he played
great for years he just didn't have
he didn't have that thing he didn't have
the playoff victories so now he was on
three in the playoffs now he's four and
three with a super bowl victory and a
hall of fame stat line so you know for
his career so
you know he really solidified himself as
a great player
and they look good moving forward if
they can resign the people that they
have
so you know
then the game turned into a game and
then uh you know joe burrows started
doing that thing he does man you know
hitting chase hitting the other dude or
the whatever and then the running back
was balling
um it was it was just like it was just
like damn is since he gonna win this
game like i was like
you know it just was like that kind of
excitement going into that point in the
game and then jalen ramsey was having a
tough time on the outside you know did
jamar chase that chase was just getting
you know
autumn receivers was just going to work
and you know joe burrow just joe cool
just doing his thing i mean he had a
really great game he was efficient you
know he just you know it just in the end
he didn't he didn't do the job you know
in the end it wasn't him versus stafford
in the end it was him
versus
the defense and even more importantly it
was him versus the offensive line the
defensive line though it was the
quarterback and the offensive line
versus that defensive line and that
defensive line won
i mean
aaron donald who might be one of the
greatest defensive players ever
you know you you have the arguments
already that they feel like he is the
greatest defensive player ever there's
people that never saw lawrence taylor
play so they don't know what that was
like all they know is this guy and you
just see these football aficionados you
see all these ex-football players that
like know the game when they watch it
they can see the moves he does like
we're layman we don't know like we watch
the game and we don't know like what a
you know a swim move or all the dumb
things that they these little
terminology they have for what defensive
players do on the line we don't know you
know what i mean we're just looking like
oh did he sack him or not or how could
he you know we don't know all the little
like you know how the slide coverage and
the how the center is supposed to go
over and help and you know all that
stuff that like football people know you
know what i mean so
you know they they just they did the job
and so like that last two plays
you know it's like third and one and the
running back goes and aaron donald's
being he's being blocked and he takes
his left arm and he goes around and he
snags the running back and literally
stops him
i was like oh my god what a play because
they were already close to field goal
coverage dude 17 yards to chase uh nine
yards to the other receiver and i'm like
oh my god joe burrows about to do this
like joe burrow's about to go down and
score or at least tie the game and i'm
like come on rams this is what the game
really was the best team on the field
the best two teams on the field on that
super bowl were the rams defense and the
cincinnati offense those were the best
two
teams on the field there's four teams
playing two offenses two defenses the
rams lost their number two receiver
they were struggling they couldn't run
the ball
it was just
stafford and cup
and then you had this so they were the
worst to me they were the worst of the
teams that were on the field the best
with the rams defense
since he's offense cincy's defense and
then the rams offense it just they just
came big when they needed to so
here they are
third down
aaron donald
stops him
and then the play of his career
they should have counted it as a sack
dude rushed around the left side
just does that offensive line is boo boo
and he just like oh man it was just
that's how you win the super bowl they
won the super bowl on a defensive play
so i think joe burrow will have a chance
to go back
he's real joe cool you know what i mean
he's a cool dude
cool under pressure i think he was hurt
did you know when he hurt his knee and
he was screaming they showed that clip
and i was like oh man that he might have
tore his mcl or something they i haven't
read any reports
let me look on right now that i'm online
right now let me just look and see let
me see did anybody hear anything
um
if he like tours acl or something like
that i just i just felt like
something was up there you know
oh see oh it was a knee sprain but i see
here it goes uh joe bro reportedly won't
need surgery for a super bowl following
knee sprain so he had a knee sprain you
know what i mean and so i don't think he
was himself
i think he would if he was more himself
he might have been able to run for a
first down you know what i'm saying it
was a tough it was a tough situation but
kudos for him for standing in the pocket
and taking all that right
so
that was great you know and then you
have
so who's the mvp so you know you have
three choices for mvp you have
um matthew stafford cooper cup and aaron
donald and they gave it to cooper cup
but like man the dude on the final drive
it was literally
stafford and cooper cup versus
the uh cincinnati defense
how you let
the only receiver really of any merit
be the guy that kills you like that
is bananas to me but what do i know just
because you know somebody is is their
only option it don't mean you can stop
him and since he just couldn't stop him
man it was crazy
i mean and then like you know when
cincinnati threw that one touchdown the
guy clearly
face masked uh janellian ramsey he falls
down the guy scores a touchdown that
would have been the talk if if
cincinnati would have went on to win the
game just everyone would have been
talking about that past interference
right so thank goodness rams won so we
don't have to deal with that
but you know it just was really uh
i mean it really was a fantastic game
you know i don't know how else to say it
so you have mvp so cooper cup was like i
think he was like
there was like a 15 16 play drive
and cooper cut was a part of nine of
nine of the plays
it's like damn yes this is live hello
mario welcome to riffin with griffin
everybody live if you're listening later
if you're listening to the podcast later
uh you know sometimes i do it live so
you know make sure you know subscribe go
to youtube so you can see all the
pictures and stuff that i have on there
but thank you for listening thank you
for watching and make sure you all that
stuff so
yeah man
it was uh
uh yeah higgins higgins like he did a pi
but you know it just was it just was a
really outstanding game and so i think
cooper cup i'm not mad that he won the
mvp it's only been like eight times i
think that a receiver has won the mvp in
the super bowl
you know and uh you know because the
quarterback just i mean the court the
quarterback just didn't do enough
if matthew stafford
and it's also
it sucks that his receivers and tight
ends didn't step up though the other
ones other than cooper cup because if he
would have started hitting those guys
you know like passes to the tight end if
those other crazy receiver names they
have crazy names if he would have like
hit them and they would have caught some
balls and he would have got like 350
yards and like whatever i think matthew
stafford would have been the super bowl
mvp but you know you you look and see
what cup did
fourth down
they run a a receiver sweep
wide receiver sweep they get it to cup
he scores like the dude was just
fantastic the dude you know right now
it's hard to not say that cooper cup is
the best receiver in the league so
kudos to cooper cup for for what he did
and then they had um you know
they had i mean it's just
joe burrow had his chance like that's
how you become a legend he had his
chance to become a legend
your ball
you dream about that
it's the super bowl you are down you
need a touch you need a field goal or a
field goal to tie you need a touchdown
to win
let me see what you got baby and he
didn't have it
he didn't have it by no fault of his own
though man i mean like he did i think
the dude's a baller they need to really
solidify that offensive line who knows
if they'll be back next year though it's
hard to say because if you think about
it
um
like
you know you talk about kansas city's
gonna be back buffalo's good
uh the ravens will get their injuries
stuff in in gear you got that team
tennessee is still good you know
remember they had the number one seed
maybe they'll trade ryan tannehill maybe
they'll try to get a better quarterback
i mean the afc is just stacked so who
knows if
the um cincinnati bengals can get back
so we'll see
but
it was one of the best super bowls i've
ever seen it was so exciting my gambling
made it even better just because i was
so excited that i was like i'm actually
going to win this bet so many years i
don't win like maybe the team i pick
wins but i
excuse me but i picked like the over
and then
and they hit the under you know what i
mean like it's that kind of stuff that
happens all the time to me
so you know it is what it is this is one
of the years i really felt good about it
um
so we'll see i mean you remember you
guys don't you you young people don't
know about dan marino but dan marino was
a phenom too and he only went to one
super bowl he went to super bowl his
like second year rookie year second year
i forgot what it was and he never went
back to the super bowl i mean we may
never see joe burrow in the super bowl
again i mean they just
excuse me they just had a phenomenal run
and they just they didn't do it what are
you supposed to do so
they needed to close the deal and they
didn't so that was pretty cool
so now
um
let's talk about
uh
the halftime show
so
i thought it was great
i i i think they were missing some
people i think ice cube should have came
out
you know what i mean but they couldn't
have nwa though that's the thing
nwa because if you know what nwa stands
for
i think i think the nfl was already
nervous enough having these people
you know like it's like rap and you know
it's like who knows what's going to
happen i mean almost was a controversy
because eminem was kneeling and i don't
know if that was part of the plan or not
so i don't know
but it just was like it was it was cool
to see but like i was waiting for some
nonsense to happen and then i was like
okay no nonsense is gonna happen and
then you just enjoyed it
it was funny to see how old everybody
was
you know 50 was thick
50 was thick thick and it's just funny
to see how like it's just it was just
some old ass men rapping you know that
you know and then snoop dogg is just
like i mean how iconic is snoop dogg
right like just how i like he's such a
character man and he's like you know
even in his like as he's getting older
he's like oh dude man what snoop dogg
might be 50 or something and he's just
out there like and i was like yeah just
out there jamming having a good time
quit walking and stuff i'm just like
snoop dogg is something else man he's
just becoming that he's just like a
lovable gangster you know what i mean
and he's just that guy and so that it
was all that stuff was good they they
did a bunch of the old hits that set was
dope um i'm just like i'm not a big uh
what was the other guy the little guy
that was rapping um
why am i forgetting his name um
come on uh help me out here uh
chat
the the the little dude that had the
boxes and you know i certainly remember
his name i'm not i feel like i'm so old
i don't even know
uh um
what was going on but then they had mary
j blige so it was like a really good
like
old school west coast sort of
that west coast vibe
from
you know
from uh
what do you call it um
back in the day you know what i mean so
that i thought that was pretty cool you
know what i mean
kendrick lamar thank you
thank you guys kendrick lamar like i'm
not a huge kendrick lamar fan
you know i think he's great i think he's
really artistic he's a really artsy
fartsy guy but like i ain't jamming to
like kendrick lamar's songs you know
they don't have they're not musical
they're not you know what i mean he's
really one of those artist guys like a
poet you know and everything has a
meaning and depth and it's just like but
i don't find that always entertaining so
i'm not super into kendrick lamar but
i'm old like that you know what i mean
so it's like all you catching lamar fans
you know i'm not i ain't hating on him
at all i just he ain't just he ain't my
cup of tea you know what i mean but he's
like one of those guys he's got messages
and he's like you know he's trying to
change the world with his music and that
kind of stuff and i go okay there's a
time and place for that
you know he's like a hippie rapper you
know and i i just it's just like i say
it's just not my cup of tea especially
next to
what we were watching with you know the
dr you know double g snoop dogg you know
all that stuff was going on and then you
got kendrick lamar he's trying to be
like i'm you know i'm gonna make a point
and it's just like okay that's cool just
not my thing but he did a great job it
was a fantastic performance mary j blige
and then eminem came out who arguably
eminem is arguably one of the best
rappers of all time like eminem you
could argue eminem like you go jordan
and lebron if you're somebody that
thinks eminem's the greatest rapper ever
you have an argument that's what i like
about him so kudos to eminem but i'm
just surprised that's the song he chose
to do i know that was the oscar-winning
song and you know lose yourself in the
moment you know but i would have i would
have liked to hear my name is or some of
his other jams i wish he would have done
more than one song but it would have
been nice to see like who else do you
think
that should be the poll you know what i
mean
that should be that that should be the
poll
uh
that's like uh well i can't i can add
the options like give me some options
guys for the poll you know like i would
have loved to have seen like uh like i
said ice cube
like you know i would have i would have
liked to see an ice cube come out there
i would like to have seen like who else
like who else is like some of the people
like you know
the the the the west coast like the west
coast vibe
of people that would have been great to
see
uh you know could be be out there
you know what i mean but i think slick
rick doug you fresh and all those guys
they're more east coast i'm just talking
about like because it was sort of like a
west coast vibe even though i don't
think mary j blige is from the west
coast but she was down with that crew
you know i wish they would have done the
tupac hologram that would have been dope
you know what i mean
uh you know have him out there
and
um
you know
it just it just was like i would i would
have liked yeah thank you like cypress
hill would have been dope that's a good
one
like who would you have liked to see who
just should yeah they should have went
via satellite to suge knight in jail
that would have been dope
sure got there like i better get these
royalties you know like i just think
they would have had some some people but
iced tea was more what east coast too i
see was the east coast guy it just would
have been nice to see some like some of
those old school dudes come out
you know some of those west coast vibe
guys come out and see
you know
so there you go
so we got a poll going in uh in the chat
that's the first time i've done that
because i'm a one-man show so uh yeah um
i thought the halftime show was good and
i felt like there was like a vibe of
like let's see if this works there is a
sort of like i don't know if it's a
racial component or not but there is
something about when it's rap there's
like a feeling of like oh man are they
gonna mess this up you know i i kind of
got this vibe of like you know let's
make sure this is perfect we don't want
any like we don't want somebody's titty
coming out we don't want anybody cursing
we don't want anybody like making some
sort of statement that's going to make
people uncomfortable it was it was
almost like everybody was on their p's
and q's man it felt like that i felt
like let's do a flawless show so next
year we can have jay-z and and whoever
else and you know kanye whoever i don't
know i don't know if you could ever have
kanye do a super bowl halftime because
he who knows what he might say but you
know what i'm saying like
it's um
it was it was good i really enjoyed uh
the halftime show right
you know and and like i say it was it's
something about snoop dogg
he's just so cool
you know what i mean like he's like a
cool ass old uncle now and he's just
like oh uncle snoop is here that's how i
feel every time i see snoop he's like
america's you know gangster uncle you
know what i mean ex-gangster uncle you
know what i mean like and he's just you
just love
i i so like kudos to snoop the halftime
show was great the game was great it was
good to see everybody out there having a
good time enjoying themselves
i didn't see one mask not a mask in
sight
they go into all the booths
nobody was wearing a mask thankfully
it's like we need to just end that
nonsense
just end it that more pictures of the
mayor
standing around no mask on talking to
people it's like what are we doing what
are we doing okay let's stop it already
stop this nonsense
so people can like live their lives man
i was on my flight home from vegas man
flight home from vegas and i'm sitting
next to this dude i didn't get the
upgrade
so i'm sitting with the riff raff
dude sitting next to me right here and
he's just he keeps talking to the
stewardess the flight attendant excuse
me
um that guy up there doesn't have his
mask on he hasn't had his mask on the
whole time just like at a loud like i'm
gonna be not obnoxious and let everybody
know how i feel about this level man
you know it just it really
it it ticked me off
uh because i was like dude let this go
like who did you lose i felt like that's
the thing like something personal to him
his mom his grandma his aunt somebody
personal to him died so now he got to be
the police for everybody and i was like
man did you i was thinking to myself you
gonna make this super uncomfortable and
then the lady came over he put his mask
on and the guy's like you know he's had
it off the whole he just wouldn't let it
go so like let's lift it all so once you
like imagine you lift the mask mandate
and you go hey if you want to wear mask
you wear a mask but everyone else you
know you don't have to i mean that's how
it should be anyway so that guy right
there where your mask homie wear your
mask if i don't have to i'm not going to
mind your business
because this guy would have turned it
into like a fight or something it would
have got out of hand and i'm like i'm
just trying to get home on my flight
without a hitch so you know we'll see
where that's going with that so we'll
see where that goes
yeah man so
that was my super bowl
recap
all right
so let's now go back to
um
let's go back to the sponsor of the show
doordash guys doordash i love doordash
you know um i love all these kinds of
things but doordash in particular
because you could get groceries you can
get household essentials you can get a
lot of stuff that you need delivered
right to your door
you know sometimes you don't want to go
to the grocery store you do and you
forgot something boom you call doordash
they support all your local favorite
restaurants it's quick it's easy it's
comfortable and this pat in the past
years taught us to save savor we should
be savoring every moment together
so
if you don't like going to restaurants
right now or you just want your favorite
food from a restaurant that you don't
normally you can't go to or you just
don't have time
man doordash is the way to go if you've
ever used or you know you know what i
mean if you've ever used door dash you
know what i'm talking about that sucker
the sucker is easy if you want what you
want to eat you want it right now i want
you to use doordash along with the
restaurants you love
you can now get groceries like i said if
you crave late night ice cream rachel
and i it's always donuts with rachel and
i but ordering is easy and your items
will be left safely outside your door
when you choose contactless delivery for
a limited time our listeners get 25 off
and zero delivery fees on their first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code griffin
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app at the app
store and enter code griffin don't
forget that's code griffin for 25 off
your first order with doordash
subject to change
uh terms apply
boom
oh
man so
i'm doing um my patreon only um
episodes and so the day that the couch
was being delivered i was in the middle
of doing the episode so in that episode
i was reviewing
um
i was reviewing
um
boba fett wait what's going on here dude
i gotta get rid of all this [ __ ] here we
go here we go here we go here we go boom
i was reviewing boba fett in the middle
of it thank mike kells appreciate the
super chats guys
the super chats let's end the poll now
oh no we still got we still have a tie
so you got to keep going with the poll
super bowl half time who would you want
to see we got ice cube tupac hologram or
cypress hill see where we got there so
um
the uh um so i was in the middle of the
episode and i had to end it abruptly but
that's on patreon so i feel like i
should do my due diligence and go back
and just talk about boba fett because
boba fett is done so we're gonna end the
episode with the boba fett review
um
this is
this show i don't know what to say
i feel like
you know if i'm really being honest i
want to say i was disappointed in boba
fett i actually would have preferred
20 episodes of mandalorian and boba fett
was just in it
and then and then like it would have
been cool to be like oh we're getting a
little boba fett backstory
but one thing that this boba fett series
did for me is it cleared up the timeline
for all of it
i didn't know when this was
you know and people were sending me
messages like they knew when it was you
are all wrong now we know because of
what they did in this
and in
one of the great episodes
so this is like after returning to jedi
this is a few this is sometime after
return of the jedi
uh boba fett was living with those
people that's why they take him out of
the pit he escaped the pit you know it
was probably shortly after it's just
that he just looks he don't look like
the boba fett
from the star wars movies that look like
a skinny young man this boba fett ain't
a skinny young man you know what i'm
saying so that's the one thing that like
you know it's a little messed up like
you feel like was he older so you know
like
like that's why you felt like how long
was he in that pit did the pit keep him
alive for many years but it just turns
out he wasn't in there
for for very long and i'm ending the
poll and we're going with and it looks
like the winner is ice cube so anyway
um
but like i say
it cleared up the timeline we know
exactly where this is but then that
makes your mind wander about like well
what was going on like where where you
know like like why don't we know nothing
about this stuff at all but i get it you
know a lot of stuff happened but at
between the end of return of the jedi
and then the new part the new star wars
like many years later as skywalker is
now this old crotchety jedi who's trying
he's gone crazy on an island you know
like it's nice to find out well what
happened from that point to made what
made him crazy he must have got some
stuff going on and this is kind of
filling in the glass filling in
you they could fill in the gaps but you
know of course the universe goes on the
world goes on you know uh
luke and the people defeat the emperor
the death star blows up so what's going
on in the universe right now so this is
kind of showing that what was happening
that's what this that's that's where it
was happening after return of the jedi
the empire's been defeated and now
people are trying to scramble and to
pick up their pieces and so boba fetts
and you know tatooine or wherever he is
wherever uh the jabba's place is and
he's taking it over and he's trying to
be the
the you know the mob boss of tatooine
and uh you know here we go and so so
that clearly cleared that up but like i
was saying boba fett didn't get good
until it became a mandalorian because
even the director writer and people that
made the mandalorian they did that
episode and it just had a
completely different feel to it like it
didn't feel like the boba fett show it
felt like mandalorian and we love
mandalorians so the fact that they
incorporated mandalorian i thought was
great and then the thing that that
really was amazing was when they um
when they when they you which click like
i say which click cleared up the
timeline is when they went to
and you saw
luke
like dude the cgi in that episode was
amazing because that right there you see
him
that's freaking mark hamill you know
what i mean like however much money they
spent on that cgi to make that cgi
character look like that is absolutely
amazing like that's the future right
there where people can be whatever age
they want to be if you're going to do it
like that so that was a really amazing
episode
you know so that you know they gave uh
uh
grugo or what's what's his name it's not
groot but
i am groot no it was like whatever the
little yoda kid
i already knew what he was going to
decide spoiler alert
you know so luke gives him luke's trying
to train him to be a jedi
and
he gave him the choice so you know mando
made him like a little chain mail made
out of that mandalorian armor
and
you know so luke gives him a choice you
can take this armor and you can leave
and go be with him have your attachments
or i'll give you yoda's lightsaber and
you stay here with me and you train
i already knew he was gonna pick the
other one because
they couldn't we didn't we don't know
about what happened they would have to
show us like why later we never heard
about this little baby yoda you know
he had to be out of luke's life so i
already knew that was going to be the
choice
so
boba fett gets a little boring again
when it you know but then they hit us
with the final episode
and the final and and i just feel like
they rushed it
it kind of felt to me like game of
thrones when they you know kind of did a
eight-episode final season and we're
like really this whole big epic thing
you've been building up for for six
seasons you want to just end it in eight
episodes that's how i felt about boba
fett i mean the final it was cheesy it
was like i think it was rushed but you
know what it was still fun it was just
big battle and you know bando and boba
fett are fighting side by side and then
they they introduced this sort of like
weird like
cowboy character
you know alien cowboy guy
you know so he you know so they have
somebody major to fight against and then
like you know uh the town is you know
fighting for boba fett because the
sheriff got killed and you know it's
just like you know it was just one of
those like epic finales but it just felt
like they didn't they couldn't do it
justice because it was a tv show
you know what i mean grogu is his name
thank you
um
you know yeah maybe yeah like somebody
in the chat said gogu could have been
killed by kylo ren
yeah who knows i mean you know you're
right but i think that that would have
been like you can't just add some
history
retroactively that we because we have
our our minds we know kind of what
happened
and we never heard about that before and
i understand why we never heard about it
because you know they just came up with
it now so that's why you can't just like
retroactively be like oh let's add this
to the
to the star wars timeline that people
know about so they had to i knew he was
going to choose
and what story would that be if like
girl goo just never shows up again so
it's cool how little uh but it like i
don't know
when you look at grogu in mandalorian
when they're doing those episodes
it's kind of endearing and like you
don't mind that it's a puppet but for
some reason in this boba fett when you
see goku you you get a sense of like oh
that's not very good special effects
you know it's like it very much is like
oh they could have done better puppet
work with this
you know like you you felt the guy's
hand up its ass you know what i mean
so
i don't know it was uh
you know again like i said they had this
big epic battle and then the young
millennials that are in the show are
there fighting and people are dying and
you know
mando and boba fett are fighting side by
side and then you know then it just kind
of ends and then you're just kind of
like ah okay that's it
you know and that's it that's uh
you know oh the guy kade bane is that
the guy's name so the chat's helping all
the star wars nerds are in chat right
now helping me out
yeah so
yeah it's uh you know that that guy i
mean i i get that like there is
they have tried
in the cartoons and the clone wars and
all that stuff there is some cannon
there that they can work with but what
i'm saying is for the casual star wars
fan that just knows the movies
you don't know a lot of characters but
you do know we never heard of another
yoda you know what i mean
so you can't just
show up with another yoda and not have
us you know
say something about it
i i think i think it's weird how luke
would just let him go but maybe
when they do boba fett season two or
they carry this over into mandalorian
season three maybe this is gonna be like
a thing maybe this luke character shows
up again but man what amazing uh you
know special effects right it's just
like damn dude
so book of boba fett i'm gonna go ahead
and give it like
uh it maybe it gets like three
[Music]
woo-woos it was good
but
i would have preferred
a mandalorian longer season
with a little boba fett backstory
you know what i mean or just a better
version of boba fett the show itself
but you know it is what it is
so you know what are you gonna do
i remember guys i got
special episodes on patreon or youtube
some youtube members
and i'm gonna be talking about way more
shows like so if you have a show you
would like me to
um
if you have a show you would like me to
review or watch you have a suggestion
for me and something you think i could
talk about on the podcast please you
know let me know man
let me know because you can send me a
message and i'm going to start you know
looking to see
uh um looking at more shows because i'm
watching like the servant on apple tv
that's a great show made by mla
shyamalan probably the last great thing
he's done
um
i'm watching
i'm watching uh what do you call it um
the freaking hbo i'm like oh i finally
started peacemaker so i started
peacemaker man i'm gonna talk about
peacemaker next week or i might even do
it just on patreon but peacemaker
fantastic i am hooked on peacemaker but
shout out to my patreon people too like
i'm just going to mention a few like al
friedman
donovan harville christian torres grace
austin mike
uh andrew
fraser
christopher
ryan j jacob you know all you guys out
there anyone else that i didn't mention
thanks for being a patreon subscriber
and thanks to my youtube members too i
appreciate you guys so
there's uh um
a bunch of shows that and what's the one
the big one on hbo max um why am i
forgetting the name dude i hate that
with rue and
then the trans girl
uh all the all the drugs
with uh what's her name
um zendaya that show that's a really
great show
so make sure you guys
i'm gonna start talking about that one
too because it's just there's just
that's one of those shows that just has
a lot of realism in it and like i'm not
always a fan of seeing like what things
would be like in real life portrayed on
screen because real life is not good
it is
sometimes real life is like it's just
you don't want to be reminded of that
but this one does and it's very true
euphoria thank you
euphoria thank you chad that's why i
need you guys here
um
you know euphoria is just such a real
show with a lot of real [ __ ] happening
and it is disturbing and sometimes super
uncomfortable and it's just a testament
to the job that those actors and
actresses and whatever pronoun you want
to use are doing because they are doing
a really fantastic job so please hit me
up with the different shows you think
you want me to watch and you know if you
want to be a member please be a member
of youtube but i prefer you over at
patreon and i'm going to be doing more
stuff there man i'm finally actually
doing it so if you want to be a patreon
member uh you know i'd be more than
happy to have you so please uh you know
come come on over come on over to the
patreon come on over to the p-ron come
on over to the p-ron and remember i you
know remember to subscribe
share
hit the notifications so you can know
when i am going live i need that
um
you know and i appreciate you guys
you know for being here as always
you know you know it's not always easy
to do a podcast every week especially
when i'm part of two others because by
the way genderjan is coming back we
built a whole new studio thing that uh
so we can go do that so we can do it at
any time we want to do it that was the
hard part so please subscribe to that
too king and sting
gender gen griffin with griffin and i'm
gonna be on twitch eric griffin gaming
i'm gonna call on everything gaming
right after this so make sure you guys
check me out there
thanks for all the people that watch me
on listening to me on all the podcast
platforms thank you for that i
appreciate you there thanks for the
comments thanks for the shares and give
me some likes too i appreciate the likes
the likes helped me out the likes you
know helped grow the show
and uh you know i don't know what else
to say but
i appreciate
you guys being here and just look out
for more reviews look out for more
guests look out for more you know just
life the the
life stuff that i like to talk about so
thanks for being here and i will see you
next week
and sorry for being late but we're here
now
[Music]
rip it griffin